you may be surprised that I am wearing a
tie today indeed by informaticians I
hardly ever dress like this when they
give talks
however 60 years ago James Watson and
George Gamow for the RNA type Club the
goal of this club was to decode the
genetic code there were 20 members in
the club one for each amino acids and
the mission was to figure out which card
one's code this particular amino acids
the members of the club met twice a year
smoked cigars and DRAM drink wine and
moreover they understood the importance
of mathematics and biologists so one of
these 20 members was a famous
mathematician Nick metropolis who
actually was one of the founding fathers
of randomized algorithm however with all
these fire powers were eight Nobel
laureates in the club they have not
decoded the genetic code the horner of
the according genetic code went to
Marshall nirenberg who did it in 1961
today we will talk about arguably a more
difficult task
decoding the non-ribosomal code I am
sure that 99% of students in this class
before the class started thought that's
the only way to produce to assemble
amino acids into a protein or peptide
was to have a ribosome and to use RNA as
a template however as we learnt in the
antibiotics lesson there is another
highly unusual mechanism for producing
peptides and assembling communities into
peptide chain it's called non-ribosomal
peptide synthesis and Mohamed Merah hail
15 years ago set on the goal to decode
the
ribosomal code an extremely difficult
task non-ribosomal peptide synthesis is
performed by a giant protein called
non-ribosomal peptide synthesis or NRP
synthetase and the tasks that Marshall
was facing was this one NRP synthetase
in bacillus brevis as we learned code 10
amino acid peptide tie resided but what
particular amino acids in NRP synthetase
are responsible for synthesizing let's
say valium inter-site non-ribosomal
synthetase in streptomyces roses porous
codes for antibiotics of the last resort
called daptomycin but at the time when
my hair started it was absolutely
unclear what particular segment in NRP
synthetase in streptomyces roses porous
codes for the optimize however mara Hale
knew something you bought non-ribosomal
peptide synthesis it is perform as I
mentioned by a giant molecular assembly
line NRP synthetase and for every amino
acid being synthesized there is a
segment in NRP synthetase roughly 600
amino acid long called adenylation
domain so this adenylation domain
synthetized one amino acid at the time
and since tera siding is 10 amino acids
long there must be 10 attenuation
demands in NRP synthetase in this case
so what our particular amino acid so
what is the non-ribosomal codes that
decides what I mean acid to synthetize
well Marshall started by taking a look
at some attenuation demand and he argued
that despite let's say this 3 I'd
inhalation demands code for different
amino acid some must be something
similar in them because they all try to
accomplish the same goal
one amino acid to the growing peptide
chain he looked at Diamond acid in this
three adenylation demands and found very
little similarities there is hardly any
similarity here only three conserved
column which is statistically
insignificant however if you just start
shifting some of the sequences like I
just did you see eleven cancer columns
and if you continue doing this suddenly
you reveal 19 conserved core this is
statistically very significant which
reveals that this adenylation demand I
indeed similar we have just constructed
the conserved core of adenylation that
the next line of attack former 'hail was
to figure out which positions in this
inhalation demands I actually
responsible for coding different amino
acid of each of them are different and
he succeeded by finding eight blue
positions that are actually responsible
for specificity of amino acid synthesis
as a result Michael was able to crack
non-ribosomal code and it turn out to be
extremely complex eight amino acid
located in different parts of
adenylation de man code single amino
acid as shown on this slide but if we
were on a table if we would not move and
shift some amino acids in some sequences
compared to other we would never be able
to find conserved blue color so it now
looks like a card trick that a magic
trick that Marc he'll perform how in the
world he was able to figure out how to
align sequences in such a way that he
was able to reveal the conserved core
today we will learn how biologists
compare biological sequences but before
we move there I will tell you about one
more biological success story the story
of hand for statistic fibrosis
J we now move to 1980s when biologists
were trying to find the cystic fibrosis
gen cystic fibrosis is an often fatal
disease of the respiratory system that
produces an excessive amount of mucus a
slimy material that is secreted into
fluids such as saliva cystic fibrosis is
a rather frequent genetic disease in the
United States one in 25 people carries a
faulty cystic fibrosis J it doesn't mean
that they have cystic fibrosis but if
two people with these faulty cystic
fibrosis genes have a child there is a
25% chance that the child will have
cystic fibrosis when in the late 1980s
biologists narrowed the search for
statistic fibrosis genes to a small
regions on chromosome 7 the question
arise which particular gene in this
region is responsible for tests for
cystic fibrosis and at that time genetic
mapping techniques were limited so they
could not narrow the search
first the as a result they started to
look at these genes and decided to
compare each of the candidate genes in
these narrow regions to all known genes
and that and one of these comparisons
revealed that one of these candidate
genes on chromosome 7 is similar to an
ATP binding protein that act as
transport channel responsible for
secretion remember cystic fibrosis is
related to secretion in ATP binding
proteins are also related to secretion
that was an Iroquois moment and
biologists contract to read that this
specific candidate genes thanks to the
similarity search is actually the gene
responsible for statistic fibers they
call the gene
cystic fibrosis transmembrane
conductance regulation or CFTR and the
CFTR protein controls the flow of ions
in and out of cells inside the lugs if a
mutation happens inside the CFTR protein
that the flow of ions is disrupted and
it leads to the two cystic fibrosis in
fact it turn out that just three
nucleotide deletion in this gene disrupt
ion channels and causes cystic fibrosis
and now the time has come for us to look
at what algorithms use to align
adenylation demands or to compare
various candidate genes in the case of
search for cystic fibrosis
you